Good morning.
Let me start with a question.
What do you think is the most
important aspect of using R
successfully?
Is it being able to write
high performance code,
or making beautiful
graphics, or perhaps learning
how to write R packages?
Here's my take on it.
I think the most important
aspect of using R successfully
is being able to find and choose
the right tools for the job
that you're working on.
I think a lot of data science
projects, they got stuck,
or they're not as
successful as they
could be because they chose
the wrong tools in the project
to build on.
And once you've gone
with a certain tool,
it can be very hard to
go back and fix that.
My name is Jeroen Ooms.
I've written quite a few
R packages, some of which
you may have used.
I'm also the maintainer
of the compilers
and the build infrastructure
for R on Windows.
And I'm a staff member of the
rOpenSci group at UC Berkeley.
And within rOpenSci,
we're working
on a big ambitious new
project called R-universe.
And in essence, r-universe
is an open platform
based on Git for managing
personal R package
repositories.
So that means that once the
packages are registered,
the system will
automatically build binaries
and documentation and so on,
directly from Git every time
the package author
pushes an update.
And these can be R
packages that are also
on CRAN or Bioconductor or
just your personal R packages.
And that really doesn't
matter as long as the source
code is available from Git.
However, publishing
packages is actually
not the goal of this project.
More importantly, it is
a starting point for us
to experiment with calculating
metrics and showing
other background information
about a package that
may tell us something about
the health and the role
and the impact of a
particular project.
So towards the end
of this talk, I
will briefly explain
what R-universe does
and where this is coming from.
But mostly today, I
want to talk about why
we believe it is important
to have better tool
and to actively monitor
the status and the health
of research software.
Because I think there are
some important differences
between using open
source software
and commercial software that are
not always immediately obvious.
In particular, when it
comes to expectations
about the quality
and the lifecycle
and the participation
in open source projects.
So I hope to make you think
a little bit about things
you may want to consider when
you're going to use open source
software and some indicators
that you may want to look
for in a healthy project.
So how do we discover and
choose the best R packages?
Because R is amazing, and you
can do so many cool things
with it.
And there's very few
rules or limitations.
But this also makes the
R ecosystem sometimes
feel a bit like the Wild West
of research software, where
it can be very hard to
find the good stuff,
hard to judge if
something is trustworthy.
And suppose you're
a data scientist,
and you need to do a
particular analysis,
or you need to read a
particular file format,
or you need an HTTP client to
interface to some open data web
servers, how do you
know what's out there?
And how do if it's any good?
Or maybe you find an
article or a blog post that
mentioned interesting package.
So you read the description.
You maybe run an example.
It seems to work.
So problem solved, right?
As you probably know, anyone
can create an R package.
You just put your code
into the right format.
And then you pull
it up on GitHub
or you submit it to CRAN.
And CRAN will actually check
if the package can be installed
on Windows and Mac and
Linux and if it does not
violate any policies.
But that's about it.
There is no
gatekeeping or judgment
on the contents
of the R package.
And this is what makes open
source software so great
because anyone can participate.
But obviously, the quality of
these contributions can vary.
And what is, perhaps,
less obvious at first
is that different
package authors
have very different
ideas on what
you can expect from them
in terms of maintenance
and support and participation.
And these things
become more relevant
as you start using
R more seriously.
Now, of course, when
you're just toying around
for a homework assignment
or a one off problem,
you just do whatever
works and move on.
But if you start to really
depend on a package,
I think the dynamic
changes a bit.
Now suppose you're really
going to build an R
package in your dissertation
research or your company's data
pipeline.
At some point, you
should probably
ask yourself some questions
like who made this package?
What's their background?
Is this an expert?
What other things
have they made?
And how can you trust
the results are correct?
Has there been any peer review
or scientific publication
to accompany this package?
Is it reliable?
Does it get tested a lot?
Because if it works
for one example,
that doesn't always mean it's
going to work for any data.
And what if you have a
question about the software,
or you find a bug?
Is the maintainer going to
be available to help you?
Is the product still
actively developed?
And what are the
maintenance expectations?
Is the package even going to
be around three years from now
when you plan to finish
your dissertation?
And who else is
using this software?
Is this an established project?
Is there a large
user community where
you can maybe ask questions?
So what you do not
want is that you
become fully dependent
on a piece of software
in your research or
in your business.
And then at some point,
a problem arises.
You run into a really bad bug.
Or the thing is crashing.
Or it's depending on some other
thing that has been retired.
Or it just doesn't work
anymore in the latest
version of Windows or Mac.
And then it turns out
there is no issue tracker.
And then you contact
the maintainer,
but you get no response.
Or worse, you get a response
like, well, this package
is part of a research
project that no longer exist.
And I've since then transferred
to another university.
And I don't have time
to work on this anymore.
And this happens a lot.
I've certainly been there.
And it's good to remember
that the package author really
doesn't owe you anything.
Like, most maintainers are
very nice and very friendly.
And they are very
interested in helping you
while also using your feedback
to improve their package.
That is what open source
software is all about.
But sometimes you find
out that some software
that you were using may actually
not be in very good shape.
I think a lot of
this also comes down
to the unique lifecycle
of research software.
All software has a lifecycle.
But for open source
projects, this
is often somewhat unclear
and unpredictable.
Most projects start
out as an experiment.
And then a small fraction
of those projects,
if it works well and the
maintainer has enough time
to put into it, he
may gradually develop
into a mature established
piece of software.
But eventually, one day, all
software becomes obsolete.
And it gets retired, or
replaced with something better.
And in commercial
projects, there's
usually a license that states
that this product is officially
supported until
at least one year.
Blah, blah, blah, blah.
But in open source projects,
there's no such thing.
Things are supported, basically,
for the extent and the duration
that the author has an interest
in maintaining that thing.
For example, a lot
of research software
only exists as a
proof of concept
to a company, a
scientific paper.
And once the thing
has been published,
the author has
really no intention
of ever touching
the software again.
So if you want to actually
build on that software,
then you're basically
on your own.
But many R packages these days
they are the exact opposite.
And they are not published
for their scientific merit.
But they do something
very useful.
And it is in the interest
of the package author
to get as many
people as possible
to use the thing to maximize
the impact of the work.
So when we're using a piece
of open source software,
it can be helpful to think
for a second about where
in the lifecycle
this project is.
Is this an experiment
or a mature project?
Like, is it still
actively being developed.
Or is it something of the past?
So how should we handle this?
What are the things
you could look for when
you're shopping for R packages?
And what are indicators
that reveal something
about the health of a
project, or that may give you
a sense of what to expect?
And what are red flags to
avoid, common pitfalls?
I think we can
roughly distinguish
three categories of indicators.
The first category of indicators
are technical indicators.
And those are things that we can
measure relatively objectively.
So for example, we can look
at the dependency network.
And the CRAN
homepage of a package
already shows you the reverse
dependencies of a package.
And so those are
all the packages
that depend on that package.
So that gives you a
sense of, if the package
is trusted by other developers.
But just counting the number
of reverse dependencies
doesn't always tell
you the whole story.
Because some of these
reverse dependencies
are way more
important than others.
Or sometimes you
find a package that
is used by 10 other packages
all by the same author,
just like with
scientific citations.
So an alternative metric
that you could look at
are to count the recursive
reverse dependencies.
Or you could weigh the
reverse dependencies
by their own
relative importance.
So you get something of
a page rank statistic.
And besides
dependency relations,
other technical indicators
that you could look at
are download statistics or
project activity in terms
of releases or commit activity.
And I think it's
especially interesting
to look at how these
numbers change over time.
So that you get a sense of
the lifecycle of a project
to see if the product is gaining
traction, or if it's on its way
out, or if it has found
like a stable role
within the ecosystem.
Let's actually
look at an example
that's close to my heart.
And it's in the curl package.
So if you need a
web client in R,
you probably need something
with Curl bindings.
But there's actually two CRAN
packages that can do this.
One is called RCurl, and the
other one used is called curl.
So which one should you use?
If you look at
the CRAN homepage,
you'll find a very
similar description
and even a similar number
of reverse dependencies.
And you can confirm
this in R as well.
But if we start looking at the
recursive reverse dependencies,
we can see a much
bigger difference.
And the reason for this
is that the curl package
is used as the foundation for
some important web framework
scenarios such as
the httr package.
And also if we look at the
reverse dependencies over time,
we can see that the use of
curl has been steadily rising
over the past few years, whereas
the number of packages that you
RCurl has been pretty still.
And we can see a
similar trend if we
look at the download
statistics for these packages
over the years.
And the story here is that
the RCurl package is very old.
It has been on CRAN since
2004 and has a paper about it
from 2006.
And it was some very
pioneering work at the time.
However, a lot has
changed since then.
And the package has some
very fundamental problems.
And the maintainer of RCurl
is not very active anymore.
So we wrote the curl
package, specifically,
as a replacement for
RCurl with a modern design
to be simpler and more robust.
And it works very well.
And most users
have switched over
to this new package since then.
But the old RCurl
package is still around.
However, it's not
in very good shape.
And if you use it
today, you quickly
start running into
some of these problems.
And so I think this is
one example where metrics
can help you make a
more informed decision
and potentially save you a
lot of problems down the line.
But of course, these technical
metrics don't always work.
I have, for example, many
R packages are very niche.
And they're useful only
to a very particular,
specialized group of people.
And so the package may
not have many downloads
or reverse dependencies.
But if this is
something in your field,
it may be exactly what you need.
And the second category of
indicators I want to talk about
are social indicators.
I consider this to be
all the things that
have to do something with
the people behind the project
and the way in which
the development
and the participation
gets organized.
And in my experience,
these are, by far,
the most important
things to look
for in a healthy,
open source project.
But these are not
easy to quantify.
A lot of it just
comes down to getting
to know the community
a little bit.
So open source projects
are, for better or worse,
most of the time, maintained
by one or two people.
And there's this fantastic
book by Nadia Eghbal
from earlier this year
that I really like,
that talks about the reality
behind open source development
and why this is the case and
the consequences that this has.
And this is, again, one
of those big differences
with commercial software.
A lot of people are used
to thinking of software
as written by anonymous
engineers from a big company.
And that is just not
how it works for us.
Open source software is written
by people like you and me.
And you should
think of R packages
more like a scientific
publication or a piece of work
by a local artist or a musician.
It really matters who
is making that thing.
So the most important
social indicator
is basically, who is the author?
Like, what organizations
they are part of?
What people they
collaborate with a lot?
If they're still active
or not, then what
they're currently working on?
And based on the
type of package,
you may care about their
formal qualifications.
And if they have
an online presence
like a blog or a social media.
Another social
indicator is, basically,
how is the product managed?
Is there a public place
for reporting bugs?
And do these typically
get resolved?
And if the product is
open to contributions
from external people, and
what that process looks like?
To me, this is very important.
I believe every R
package should have
a public place where everybody
can post their issues.
So you can see what problems
other users are running into.
And people can help
each other out.
But let me be clear
that you should not
expect every R package author
to be a full time tech support
person.
Answering all of these questions
and reviewing suggestions
can be very exhausting.
And sometimes, you
just don't have time
to work on a project
for a few days
or a few weeks or a few months.
But for me, the important
thing is transparency.
If I have no way of seeing
what are the common problems
or questions with a
package, that is a red flag.
There may be some exceptions.
If the packages are
relatively small
and is maintained by
a professor that's
really the expert in
the field, it may be OK.
But generally speaking, I think
a functional issue tracker
is really a minimal requirement
for a healthy open source
project.
And finally, other social
indicators you could think of
are available resources for
learning about the package.
For example, if there's
good documentation
either by the package
author themselves
or by users writing blog post.
But for example also, if
there's many questions answered
on Stack Overflow, that
may be a great source
of information and a
sign that other people
are using this package.
And then there's a third
category of indicators.
And these are perhaps
more specific to R
because we have a little
research software.
And these are
scientific indicators.
So for packages that are
specifically implementing
some scientific method,
you are probably
interested in the
validity of those results.
And for example, if the
package is fitting some model,
you want to be sure that
the estimates are accurate
and that the package is handling
all edge cases properly.
And this is, of course,
very difficult to judge.
But there are some
things we can look at.
For example, some packages
have gone through a peer review
process.
For example, in the Journal of
Cisco Software or in rOpenSci,
that's a good sign.
It's not a guarantee
that the package will
be in good standing forever.
But at least, the
author has gone
through an effort at some
point to have a colleague have
a critical look at the code.
And of course, we can look
at citations of packages
in scientific publications.
This is very tricky
because many researchers
don't cite software.
And if they cite they
probably just cite
R or Tidyverse and not
the individual packages.
But what is interesting is
that many journals these days
are starting to require
researchers to include
the analysis code
with their publication
for reproducibility purposes.
And so you can imagine
if a lot of code
becomes available
this way, we can
start to analyze
some of this code
to see which R
packages are commonly
used in scientific research.
So I think the scientific
quality of R packages
is by far the most difficult
to judge but is very important.
All right.
So why am I talking
about all of this?
So in rOpenSci, we want to help
researchers to get the most out
of R. So we do curation,
and we reorganize
peer review of R packages.
And we provide some
development infrastructure.
And recently, we've been
increasingly feeling
the need for better
tools to actively monitor
the quality of R packages.
And this is both for
our internal projects,
but also for the R
ecosystem as a whole
to be able to better advise
researchers on what to use.
So we've started working on this
new project called R-universe.
And on the one
hand, R-universe is
an extension of our internal
built infrastructure.
So in rOpenSci, we
have a doc server
which automatically builds
packaging and documentation
for all of R packages.
And we have a
CRAN-like server which
automatically builds
the binaries for all
of our packages.
And this works very well.
And with R-universe, we
basically want to enable other
organizations to take advantage
of these same tooling.
But we want R-universe
to not become
just a build system
but also a place
where you can learn more
about these packages.
So we're going to try to
combine some of these hard data
that you get from
the build system
with other source of
information about the authors
and activity in the lifecycle
and all these things
that we've talked about.
And then we have
someone else that
work on the scientific metrics.
So they are
developing tools that
can help us find citations
and mentions of packages
in scientific publications.
And besides showing information
about a single project,
we also want to help with the
discovery of other software.
And so by cross-referencing
similar packages or other work
by the same author or the
same organization, maybe
we can build something
of a recommender system.
And finally, we want this to
be a place that says something
about the impact and the
importance of an R project
in order to help package
authors get credit
for research software
in the same way
as this happens for
scientific publications.
So this was my talk.
Thank you for listening.
I hope it got you thinking
a little bit about the world
behind open source development.
And if I got you interested
in R-universe project,
keep an eye on our website,
r-universe.dev where we will
start adding more of the things
that we're working on over
the upcoming year.